be nice la sposa si dovremo costruire
per sopravvivere a ogni turno usciranno
fuori decreti gregorio
o no
ma prima di iniziare voglio parlarvi di
questo fantastico gioco games in impact
in questo gioco inizierai un'avventura
magica nel continente di te e bat dove
puoi interagire con l'ambiente
puoi arrampicarti nuotare e persino
planare con le ali in questo bellissimo
mondo puoi usare il potere di diversi
elementi per sconfiggere i nemici e
risolvere gli enigmi esplora le varie
regioni tutte con paesaggi mozzafiato
puoi anche giocare con i tuoi amici fino
a un massimo di quattro amici è davvero
facile immergersi in questo mondo
bellissimo e magico nel nuovo
aggiornamento 2.5 troverai tante nuove
cose che rendono questo gioco ancora più
divertente ci saranno ad esempio nuovi
personaggi disponibili via emico ci
sorprenderà con la sua intelligenza e
astuzia e torneranno i personaggi
classici raiden shogun e salgono miyako
comi in questa versione 2.5 io vi
suggerisco di provare le storie di via
emico e raiden per saperne di più su
questi personaggi ci saranno inoltre
anche nuove storie un nuovo boss con una
grandissima katana nuovi nemici ognuno
con caratteristiche uniche e tre nuovi
fantastici eventi gensini in parte
davvero uno dei giochi più belli
disponibili grazie alla sua grafica
storie personaggi e tanto altro
non perderti questo bellissimo gioco
scaricalo ora e gratis ed è disponibile
per pc android ios playstation 4 e 5
clicca nel link descrizione per
scaricarlo ora
[Musica]
noi dobbiamo costruire la nostra base
per
preso animati del tesoro sono tantissimi
sono altissima minuto mi stanno
affacciando sto costruendo bastano
troppo limitato
andiamo a trovare vitale vediamo se lui
ha costruito qualcosa che come
proteggersi vediamo vediamo ecco i 9 ei
fattori taglia
sulla testa di agli one
mi sto aspettando ancora svariati
guardiamo costruire delle mura altissime
ma una casa qualcosa che mettono sempre
qui da me l'amico proteggermi da te
allora ma mai hanno costruito una casa
tre invece una casa fantastica possiamo
salire anche qui sulle scale per
proteggerci e che invece sono scavati
col puro qui viaggi luoghi sono tutti là
sopra ok sono spariti abbiamo un momento
di tregua per coprire ancora adesso
proverò a coprire la scala delle mura
altissime ma ho capito della sua volta
che giochiamo a questo gioco quindi non
siamo molto bravi e morire però ci sono
alcune persone che sono super bravissimo
in questo gioco costruisce per
sopravvivere tipo guardate quella carta
celeste li ha fatto tipo anche una
piscina qualcosa ora piscina e qualcuno
è venuto a trovarmi e non ti conviene
ripararti quando le mie mura perché sono
un po scadenti ha perso che cattivi
riprenderanno subito senti ripari cuamm
e cambiamo colore della nostra
costruzione
comunque se questo video raggiunge i 6
mila mi piace faremo un altro episodio
in cui giochiamo a
sopravvivere magari diventeremo più
brave o no
murario
ho messo descrive l'altra sera per
salire braccino aiuto dove sono vv io
continuo a costruire perché non vedo
nessun cattivo ancora a proposito di
cose paurosa avete preordinato il mio
libro storico oro da scuola di mister è
un libro che parla di amicizia
coraggio scuola non voglio sbagliare
vitro babar cliccate nel link
descrizione potrete leggere la trama e
tantissime altre curiosità e potrete
appunto preordinarlo che cade l'alibi
del fritto rete non avete ancora
preordinato
[Musica]
o no ma poi passare a saltare così in
alto io non riesco dovuto mettere nei
calcoli nuovo ulcere agli one e formia
strage dosatori noto
è davvero difficile
costruire mentre mettevano
una piastra ho deciso di andare nella
costruzione di vitale magari sera
ripararmi di più diamo come sono le mura
di vitale io sto facendo delle scale le
scale
sei molto più bravo di me a costruire
soprattutto
bene io rimarrò qua dai sbrigati ca
turistica se io davvero ho dubbi pure tu
accostando che non posso costruire qua
venivano poi costruire noti come non è
il mio fatte non posso costruire
veramente peccato se non avremmo potuto
ridere e difendersi dagli arrivi di euro
resta vivo solo 20 secondi prima che
arrivi la dai
quando sono in atto ancora più in alto
no non mi va a costruire a ok allora
ancora più in alto mettiamo prima delle
scale forse non riusciranno a 6000 pasto
prada c'è perché qualcun altro che è
venuto
prossimo cattivo estate quando non c'era
dov'è lo vedete da qualche parte non
vedo niente ore sto costruendo
giostro grossissimi illustrativi che
devo ammettere sembra un mix tra badia
kiwa chi li vedete
io mi sono protetto che
non ci credo vitale riuscito a partorire
qualcosa che si fronteggiano murato
nuovo funziona questa
sei stato bravo aspetta aspetta adesso
faccio ma ne faccio un posto anche per
te genere riescono a salire qua sopra
non gli estratti di regione sono io
mi sto proteggendo mi sono curato con te
ti trattano tornata nella mia
ricostruzione orribile ma come fai a
uscire ha deposto distruggere i
blocchetti le ho cambiato idea andiamo
alla stendersi nella costruzione di
qualcun altro che magari è fatta bene
perché non sai come sequestro il rischio
quando si può salire come fanno a salire
pasto oprah costruzioni di vita essa
impreparato adesso sembra che stai
davvero costruendo dei leggo però non ha
funzionato quindi devi farlo più
resistente si dice secondi arrivano che
prova nascondermi qua in questa
costruzione di quest altro giocatore
molto in alto quindi forse non
arriveranno qua wow che bella questa
costruzione
costruendo sono i cattivi
con il vestito di essa
si muovono fanno morra molto strano solo
un modo per animali ma perché cielo 67
da me qui siamo tutti qui salita da me
aiuto aiuto povera vita alta preferenze
ruotolo
che bello ok andiamo a vedere ora la
costruzione di vita le coperte tra un po
non riuscirai più a salire e fatto una
torre la torre di vitale e con margaro
le scale perché sono anche loro riescono
a salire
ecco qua abbiamo messo un'altra versione
di costruisci perso creduto possibile e
io ho già costruito una sorta di
fortezza però il problema
non c'è spazio dentro guarda dei colori
e microscopica però dentro non resterà
che piano sera con normali si riescono
ad entrare loro ma poi penso se vuoi
togliere qualcosa basta premere con
l'aic riesci toglierle no va bene sapevo
che c'erano le lucane qua ecco come hai
fatto tu a costruire le serali
e poi che cos'altro si
materiali cane o c'è anche la regolano
portiamo che il primo
ma ci sta
dopo tra caso troppo piccolo l'ogiva
diete
non
dovevo uscire dalla mia casa
mi ha cambiato la vita l'ho portato io
posso costruire l'acqua sopra aspetta
vengo a trovarti così forte e riccò
proteggermi ecco vita è laggiù è meglio
se ti sbrighi
smentite ecco quando riescono a salire
vero a punto pare non stai costruendo i
suoni così posso fare tutto il perimetro
della casa vorrei poterti aiutare ma
purtroppo non posso costruire intaccato
infatti sarebbe bello costruirlo insieme
e qualcuno laggiù ha costruito una sorta
di trampolino
guardate che bravo vitale ha già fatto
così tanta paura e guardate in confronto
la mia casetta che è morta possiamo fare
una casa gigante quello possiamo
arredare e prova a costruire qualcosa
altra prova operai ormai io sono una
piazza nel costruire sicura che non puoi
costruire che non puoi costruire anche
qui da me no purtroppo lo ha un'idea
metterò prima arredamento e poi
costruirò le mura un'ottima idea un
divano e invece dare lavorate potrei
fare una per tremare i muri t.silva
con il pozzo prima ma con delegato
40 forse sono più grandi vediamo se i
cattivi riusciranno a sorpassare i
divani che non vi fa mettere il letto o
no che così robot dei letti o questo
troppo onore che sono qui e che stavi
votò no eh eh lo so dove può premio che
questo nuovo gioco aiuto chi è questo
cattivo
o paura aiuto come sempre risolta noti
accecata anch'io guardate che bella
costruzione ho messo cinque letti 2 e
john vi proteggono per niente
ios o si stanno pure prendendoli allora
siccome io sono super schiappa in questo
gioco
andiamo è rubiamo la costruzione a vita
come rubiamo ricorda è stata
sfracellarsi ancora non sono riuscito a
chiudere tutte tutte le mura di
perimetro forse è meglio che fai un po
più di altezza quando si
arriverà kimwaki e kiss the mist i
10 post guarda microscopico stanchi di
prima allora lui non arriva qui da noi è
vero qualche piccolino
le fortezze guardate stanno saltando lì
ma non riescono a rivale da lui che
soddisfazione finalmente non essere
stress e la team anni fa ho detto non è
arrivato qui da noi
come non detto
[Risate]
la mia costruzione calcina
no è stato sfracellando dopo quando te
ne vanno via a chi fa adesso sono andata
via a costruire allora come fanno a
salire pure qua sopra assurdo bisogna
stare in alto per proteggersi loro
aguzzino a fare qua i muri arredate
vitali ha quasi completato i muri mi
dispiace non poter che aiutare beh io
rimango qua dove contano a costruire
muri magari riesco a fermarmi un
pochettino penso che quel muretto
scavalcheranno subite adesso faccio pure
il resto
davvero non me ne sono accorto treno
rotolini eccoli sono arrivato uno
tsunami come noi dobbiamo proteggerci
bisogna fare le mura alte
spiaccicato
me non mi ha buttato giù i muri per
fortuna non ha distrutto niente è però
devo dire che la divertente che super
divertente questo gioco però finché non
riusciamo a costruire qualcosa di
decente morire potersi radici qualche
consiglio nei commenti beh non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi per entrare
a far parte della per il riposo il
prossimo cattivo story 4 prezzo fail
ovvero di già è già arrivato c'è scritto
che i ragazzi si chiama fox i kings e
foxy forse quello di fight night 3d o no
dove non vedo nessuno è come sembra il
muro che sto costruendo molto bello
bravissimo che è successo a giudicare
dalle urla stanno arrivando eccolo sia
quello di fi prima di tutto le discrete
ma è successo anche successo a youtube
compreso non so come sono riuscito a
sopravvivere solo quello avevo preso
sono tornata la mia bellissima
costruzione forse qua non si avvicinano
nemmeno perché dicono che è pronta
andiamo io rimango qua no no no no sono
riuscito fuori dalla mia mura e visto
che seguendo ieri povera qua siamo
sopravvissuti che belle le mura di
vitale ma tu ce la fai poi ad entrare
ci sono riuscita ma non posso più uscire
altrimenti poi non riuscirò mai più a
centrare da evitare costruiscimi una
bella casetta se
guardate che penso di montecopiolo
questo arrivando pennywise o no
pagliaccio prezzo prezzo chiedi chi è
libero come credente sa credo non ci sto
riuscendo però faremo in tempo a
proteggersi con eccoli ragioni vedete mi
sa che stanno arrivando sono tantissimi
speriamo che non lo rivelo qua vedi in
quella torre lì non riescono a salire e
quindi poi quando non riescono a entrare
vanno tagliate dagli altri di quanti
da noi siamo gli unici che abbiamo delle
costruzioni scade mai conosciuto un
castello è questo il numero dei
bravissimo state sono tutti l'azzurro
meno male a lui si stanno lasciando
tranquillo invece le forze che stanno
facendo lì come ha fatto lei a
proteggersi da loro strano o no l'hanno
presa
forse non è la prima volta che travolto
proprio il prossimo cattivo sta
arrivando si chiama kitten kit un gatto
ma sarà un gatto no guarda il gigante
mezzo poi lo conoscete ho detto così fa
così posso fare cosa mi aspetto
quest'anno saputo che sono riusciti a
passare tre persone mura perché le mura
perché loro sono giocati
invece invece sono vivo ancora
strettamente sappiamo se mi nascondo
dietro non stanno arrivando pure
quotidiano aiuto come sera perché sono
giganti vedi la carretta dimostra ecco è
questo ancora sopravvissuto dai scappa
non ti fermano ha trovato il sistema
basta andare in torno qui alle mura
ancora dieci secondi
rimasti incastrati quattro sono 32 ora
sono vissuti
stiamo accusando blello vice ali da
allora dobbiamo fare le mura più alti
leggerci altrimenti i cattivi quelli
grandi riescono ad entrare martella giu
qualcuno sta costruendo a di wacom ha
fatto i piedi di agguati le gambe e poi
piano piano lo costruirà fido
pratica
l'impostore diamo gas davvero non lo
vedo beh dovrebbe essere piccoli non ho
allora forse riusciamo a proteggerci
eccoli bruciati non riusciranno a salire
qua perché sono piccoli niguarda è
venuto qualcuno stanno sparando da
questo questo giocatore è venuto qua a
proteggersi da noi a dire che abbiamo
costruito un bel castello fortino
feretro è arrivato popolo di reggersi
stanno arrivando ligresti sono dietro di
noi è successo questo giocatore sta
succedendo qualcosa di strano è la vita
sparandosi
io continuo a costruire uno solo
incontrare non ci credo sei stato
bravissimo però pure hanno protetto
ancora 14 secondi qua
e anche grazie a questo giocatore che ha
eliminato bel po di impostori grazie se
ne sta andando bene però la prima parte
ti costruisci per
sopravvivere ma ha fatto da montarsi
quel giocatore non avete ancora
preordinato storie paurose andati a
preordinarlo lasciate ubp un bel mi
piace rovi lasciamo quindi cari per
vedere inoltre altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite